[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, and welcome
to the 11th weekly episode
of the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my co-host, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Very excited about this episode,
touching something that I think
is very controversial--
at least the name.
I know a lot of people
that don't really like it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Talking about
Internet of Things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
Internet of Things, yeah.
What it really is, and why is
everybody talking about it?
MARK MANDEL: It's a pretty
popular, though, topic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, to the point
that we have a developer
advocate in our own team that--
MARK MANDEL: He's pretty active.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --works a lot
on-- yeah, works a lot on it.
So we're going to
have her today.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But before that,
let's talk about the
cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
So you pointed this out
to me earlier today.
I thought it was
pretty interesting.
Udacity has a deep
learning course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I saw that on Twitter,
the Google Cloud Twitter.
Yeah, it's actually
very interesting
because I know that there was
a bunch of courses around about
machine learning--
some of them created
by Google-- but this the
first deep learning course.
So deep learning--
what does that entail?
Well, it's not only
about neural networks.
But it's more about
what kind of information
you can extract out of,
basically, everything.
It's quite interesting
because it's actually applied.
So they show you all the theory.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
According to Udacity,
it's around a
three-month course.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's free.
So I think--
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: It's
worth mentioning
it is built by Google, like it's
a Google program in conjunction
with Udacity.
It does talk about
TensorFlow as well,
which we've talked about
previously, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: But it says it's an
intermediate to advanced level
course.
But it sounds like it
could be pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that you will
definitely need some bases
on machine learning.
But at the end of
this course, you
should be able to use TensorFlow
like a pro, basically.
So I think, if you have the
time to go through the course,
I could definitely do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
That sounds like
it'd be really cool.
Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So let's go talk with
our colleague Jen Tong.
MARK MANDEL: Why not?
Let's do it.
So we're joined today by one of
our most illustrious coworkers,
Jen Tong.
Jen, how are you doing today?
JEN TONG: Doing great.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: Very, very well.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
JEN TONG: Of course.
MARK MANDEL: So
we wanted to talk
to you about Internet of Things
and that sort of fun stuff.
But why don't you
let us know who
you are, what you do,
your background, so people
have an idea of who you are.
JEN TONG: Sure thing.
So hi, everybody.
I'm Jen.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
And I focus on Google
Cloud Platform.
That means, in a nutshell, that
I help people cause trouble
with code or build cool
stuff and then, you
know, join them in the
satisfaction of accomplishing
something great.
And along the way, I
help people understand
why cloud technologies
are awesome and can
make their life easier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Do you focus on any
particular products and stuff?
I mean, obviously, we want to
talk about Internet of Things.
But I'm just kind of curious.
JEN TONG: Yep.
So kind of the
area I focus on is
parts of the Cloud to either
make IoT prototyping really
easy-- which is I guess what
we'll be talking a little bit
more about today-- but also
the other side of the equation,
is Internet of Things devices
are really good at generating
a whole bunch of data.
So I spend a lot of time
focusing on the big data
side of that, things
like BigQuery and Pub/Sub
and Bigtable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Yes.
Cool.
So I'm a little bit curious
about the Internet of Things.
I've heard many
definitions of it.
What is yours?
JEN TONG: The Internet
of Things the way
I define it is any device that
didn't used to be associated
with internet
connection-- so something
smaller than a laptop,
smaller than a smartphone,
usually-- that connects
to the internet
and then allows you to access
it in ways that you did not
previously expect, so
using the same [INAUDIBLE]
protocols and other
languages that we use to do
anything else on the internet.
MARK MANDEL: So what would
be some examples of that?
JEN TONG: So one of
my favorite examples
is something that people
don't really usually associate
with the Internet of Things,
is the rise of Uber and Lyft
and the other internet-connected
ride share services.
And this is because
it took something
that didn't use to be connected
to the internet-- which
was essentially like cars, ride
share, taxi cabs-- and then
connected it to the internet
using people's smartphones,
which was really cool.
And then suddenly it
became a lot easier to use,
and it spawned a whole
new marketplace, which
was kind of an amazing thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I never thought about Uber or
Lyft being Internet of Things,
but it totally makes sense--
the internet of cars.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's really cool.
OK, interesting.
You could almost-- OK, so would
you classify, like, Airbnb
as an Internet of Things?
JEN TONG: Airbnb?
I don't know as much,
because there's not really
a lot of, like-- there's no
specific hardware involved.
MARK MANDEL: True.
JEN TONG: Airbnb
more, to me, seems
like a hub of payment gateways.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's more-- OK.
Fair enough.
JEN TONG: Which is
pretty cool, too,
it's just-- the houses
don't move as much.
They don't need that.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
JEN TONG: I mean, the
moment they add, like,
location specific
temperature predictions
and stuff like that, then
that would probably put them
over the edge, which
would be pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JEN TONG: Little
weather stations--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like Nest.
JEN TONG: --at each house.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Well it's like Nest, really.
JEN TONG: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, when I
thought about Internet of
Things, one of the first things
that came to mind
was a toothbrush.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that,
like it's also
Internet of Things
when you start connecting random
stuff like toothbrush or Nest--
like thermostats-- is also
that Internet of Things?
JEN TONG: Yeah,
we're seeing that
happen all over the place now.
Things that used to just be
standalone, and had their own--
potentially their own APIs.
They might've had a way to
digitally interface with them
over Bluetooth or something.
But suddenly, they're
starting to come
into existence with web servers
or other proprietary ways
of pushing data to the
Cloud like toothbrushes,
refrigerators, washing machines.
And it's suddenly making
them a lot more functional.
And then, magically,
you can use them
from any internet connected
device, which is cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
And soon, you know,
my fridge can tell me
about all the stuff I really
should have thrown out
but haven't yet already.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm still waiting for the
day when the fridge will
be able to send a
notification to my phone,
saying as like, hey.
You're running out of
milk-- stuff like that
MARK MANDEL: I want
my fridge to send
a note to Amazon saying, hey.
Just send him some
milk automatically
because he's already run out.
And then I don't even
have to do anything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's real lazy.
I like it.
Nice.
So, tell us a little bit
about how did you get involved
with the Internet of Things?
JEN TONG: So I'm going to have
to go further back on that.
My education
university was focused
on both electrical and
computer engineering.
So at the beginning
of my career,
I spent time working on
things like robotics.
In fact, I had a little
run doing robotics at NASA.
And I actually
hated it back then.
It was really hard
because we didn't
have all the cool debugging
and all the neat stuff
that the internet was bringing
to other kinds of development.
So I took a break and
focused on web development
for most of my career because
debuggers are awesome.
And then I kind
of pushed it aside
until one day,
someone's like hey.
There's this new Arduino thing.
Electronics is easy now.
And I didn't
believe it at first,
but I picked up an Arduino
starter kid and I was hooked.
And then it was just
a matter of time
before Wi-Fi shields
and other things
and allowed those
easy-to-use electronics
to start getting connected
to the internet appeared
on the market.
And then suddenly, it
was fun and easy to build
stuff that used to be
kind of a pain to build.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I'm a little bit curious
about the robot part.
What kinds of robots
were you building?
Can you share that?
Because it was NASA, so I'm
not sure if you could say,
if you could share.
JEN TONG: Oh, they were
all public projects that
have all been canceled since.
But one of the ones I
spend the most time on
was called the crew
return vehicle,
which was the escape pod
for the space station.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
JEN TONG: It's
since been canceled,
but the idea behind it was it
was a mostly automated return
system, so you
wouldn't have to have
as much training for the
pilots on the space station.
And I worked on a
physical robot test bed
for the software that did
things like automated docking
and release.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But you're
a Cloud developer advocate.
So how does the
Cloud get in touch
with the Internet of Things?
Are they the same thing?
How are they related?
JEN TONG: So it's kind
of the internet part
of the Internet of Things,
because all the electronics
and the embedded
operating systems
and all that stuff makes a thing
that could be very intelligent.
But once you attach
it to the internet,
Cloud is a logical way to
add internet capabilities.
MARK MANDEL: So are there
any particular challenges
on the Cloud side?
Like I'm guessing if you have
lots of Internet of Things,
you need to deal
with like scale,
or you talked a little
bit about big data.
Could you tell us a little
more about how that works?
JEN TONG: Yes.
There's a couple
that come to mind.
The first one is
Internet of Things
devices tend not to be the
most intelligent systems
because you're going to want
to use lower power things that
are less smart, so they tend to
generate a lot of data, which
is cool, because you can do
cool things with lots of data
like machine learning
and all that stuff,
but it is a different kind
of data than what we're
used to from web development.
So it stresses a lot of our
traditional database and REST
API systems that we've
built up to power web apps.
So we have to kind
of take a little bit
of a different approach to
handling that much throughput
of data, which is where things
like Pub/Sub and Bigtable
really shine.
Another aspect of it is
Internet of Things is also
about low power systems.
And transport layer security
is usually a big challenge,
and actually is
responsible for a lot
of the complexity in
sending data in a secure way
to the internet.
So that's one that you
usually spend a lot of watts
and a lot of effort overcoming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you have
some advice about security
on the Internet of
Things, because that's
one of the things that,
every single time I read
about Internet of
Things on the newspaper,
is because someone
hacked-- like, I read
about someone
hacking a toothbrush
and they were able to
access your password
or something like that.
Like what kind of techniques
you should implement
to avoid those things?
JEN TONG: What
kind of techniques?
A lot of this goes back to
kind of the same techniques
we're used to doing from
other kinds of development.
The first one that I
would always recommend
is don't reinvent
security yourself.
We have protocols like
transport layer security
that we are pretty
confident work really well.
Use those.
Don't try and invent your
own encryption scheme
to save a few bits of overhead.
The other aspect is--
hard off is a good way
to make sure that things
like microphones and things
can stay off when
you're not actually
using them for your device.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JEN TONG: So take
advantage of physical off.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Unplug
it and that's it.
Nice.
JEN TONG: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: The
most secure computer
is one that's not plugged
to the internet or power.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's-- that
normally tends to--
MARK MANDEL: That works.
Well, that sounds
really interesting.
So if people want
to get involved
with the Internet of Things
or they're sort of interested
in that sort of platform,
where should they go?
What should they do?
JEN TONG: So most
of the people I
talk to who are
just kind of getting
into the Internet
of Things excitement
have web development background.
So this is where I kind of steer
them in a specific direction,
is there's this really cool
growing community of people
building NodeBots.
And NodeBots is mostly
focused on the electronic side
and using JavaScript to
control robots and electronics.
But because you're
using JavaScript,
all the neat web
stuff that we've
done that work well
in JavaScript and well
in Node also work on
these robots, which
is really cool, because you
can fall back on all the tricks
and techniques and
design patterns
that you learned from building
JavaScript web applications,
except you can use them on
electronics without having
to learn a whole new
language and a whole bunch
of new frameworks.
MARK MANDEL: So what does that
sort of development process
look like?
So if I'm writing
JavaScript and I have, I
guess, some sort physical
thing, how do I connect to it?
What does that look like?
What sort of thing would I have?
I don't know.
I don't know anything
about this stuff, really.
JEN TONG: So
usually, what I steer
people to if they just want
to get started is first,
use whatever you
have available if you
have something available.
And what a lot of
people, turns out,
already have is a Raspberry
Pi and an Arduino Uno
that they picked up
from a Kickstarter
or they got at a conference.
And they're on some shelf
somewhere gathering dust.
So that's usually
the first recipe
I give people, is they install
NodeJS on a Raspberry Pi
and then use a USB cable to
plug it into their Arduino Uno
and use a protocol
called Firmata-- which
comes with Arduino SDK-- to
communicate with the Arduino,
and then do all their
electronics work on the Arduino
because it is a wonderfully
robust and durable board
and is very tolerant of
mistakes that would burn out
other dev boards.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's good.
That's one of the
things that I actually
learned quite quick,
was that, depending
on how you plug stuff, you
might burn it down, which yeah.
It's kind of sad if you
only have one of them.
Actually for me, one of
the biggest problems--
it was not the programming
part of it when I got started.
It was, for
instance, if you want
to have a little
LED that blinks,
you actually have to add
some resistors in the middle.
And I didn't know
how to do that.
What is your advice?
How do I learn these things?
JEN TONG: So my advice is not
to fear things going wrong,
and to copy things, where
possible, to get started,
because it's always easy.
Just like a software
project, it's
always easy to
start from something
that's already working.
So coincidentally, my
favorite JavaScript library--
Johnny-five, which is used
by a lot of NodeBots--
has a wonderful
documentation that
also is a really good
primer to electronics.
So whether you get it from the
Johnny-five docs or the Arduino
Uno starter pack and the
instruction manual there,
all those things have pictures
of the circuit you should build
and then an explanation of
why they should work that way,
and usually code that goes
along with it to get it working.
So at the very
beginning I wouldn't
spend a lot of
time trying to get
a deep understanding of why.
Just find pictures, copy
them, get them working,
and then explore and expect
things to burn up every once
in a while and get used to it.
And then your understanding
will grow over time,
and your bag of
tricks will improve,
and things will catch
on fire less often.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hopefully.
JEN TONG: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Now, do you
have a favorite getting
started project?
I hear blinking
light tends to be
the hello, world of
Internet of Things.
Is that kind of the truth?
JEN TONG: Yep.
So along with that recipe I
described with Raspberry Pi,
with Johnny-five and
Firmata and NodeJS
and the Arduino Uno, the
first project I usually
recommend people is an internet
button that turns on an LED.
So you wire up a button, and
when you press the button,
you send a signal
out to the Cloud.
I usually steer people
towards Firebase
for their first project.
You flip something in
Firebase, and then you
have a Firebase
client on the same
or another Raspberry Pi
that receives that signal
and then turns on an LED
when the button is down.
MARK MANDEL: Do you want
to talk a little bit
about what Firebase is and
maybe how it fits in with IoT?
We haven't really
talked about Firebase
too much on this podcast.
JEN TONG: Got it.
So Firebase was an
independent company
that got acquired by
Google in late 2014.
And it is a way to-- it's
kind of like, generally,
a bag of goodies that you can
use to build apps, like web
apps and mobile apps.
And it works really great
with JavaScript and NodeJS,
which means it also
plays exceptionally well
with NodeBots.
And the data model does
behind Firebase-- one
of the components of Firebase
being a realtime database--
is you have a big ball of
JSON in the sky, in the Cloud.
And all of your apps and devices
can write to any location.
And they can also
listen to a location.
And whenever one
of those locations
changes or has a new child
added or something gets moved,
the Firebase client
will automatically
call a callback function that
you specify in your code.
And what this does is it
makes all the multi-threading
and synchronization stuff-- it
kind of handles that for you.
So it makes building
Internet of Things devices
so much easier than
having polling loops
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds
like Firebase is probably
one of your very much
recommended starting places of,
all right, I've got all
these devices out there
and I need to synchronize
data between them either
coming in or going out.
I can just plug it
all into Firebase
and then, hopefully, magic
happens and everything's OK.
JEN TONG: Yeah.
Firebase excels at prototyping
for web and mobile apps.
And for the same strengths--
the same reasons--
it also excels at
prototyping IoT devices.
So it is wonderfully
awesome, especially
if you're building
one of something,
which is usually the first
step on an IoT project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So dwell a little
bit on Firebase.
We used it for Cloud Spin.
And one of the good
things about it
is that you build whatever
you want to build on Firebase,
and then at some point
you're like, oh wait.
We need a visualizer
to understand
that the system is doing.
And that's super simple to do
because all the data is already
on the Cloud.
So you don't need to
export anything extra.
You can just build a
new, really tiny web
page that shows whatever
you're interested on.
So yeah, if people have
not tried [INAUDIBLE],
I think it's a great
place to start.
JEN TONG: Yeah.
And up to 100
concurrent users is
part of our
developer plan, which
is free-- free forever,
which is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
That's very cool.
Very, very cool.
So I have to ask.
What have been your
favorite IoT projects?
Maybe something weird and
wacky, something somebody's
done that seems a bit
interesting and cool?
JEN TONG: So a lot of
people are interested in IoT
for saving money,
establishing new businesses,
and that kind of stuff.
But my favorite
projects tend to go back
to the crazy LED-powered
artsy scene that's
really, really popular,
especially here
around San Francisco.
And because of the declining
cost of light emitting diodes,
blinky lights, and sensors
and all that stuff,
people are building these
really cool giant installation
or even small desktop sets
of interactive artwork
that are internet connected
and allow you to interact
with the artwork
and multiple people
around you in really cool ways.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So like setting up sensors where
people walk through or touch
or play, and it sort
of responds in some
interesting and wonderful ways.
JEN TONG: Yeah.
That popular thing I'm
starting to see a lot
is all of us are walking
around with little internet
computers-- our smartphones--
and that's a really, really
great way to have
people interact
with some other already
internet-connected device.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
Very, very cool.
So you also
mentioned-- I just want
to make sure it's very
clear for our listeners
as well-- you've
mentioned a whole bunch
of different hardware,
so like Arduino
and a couple of other things.
Is that your favorite
hardware to use?
Or do you have other favorite
things that you like to use?
JEN TONG: So usually what
I recommend to people
is to use what you already have.
Anything that's-- so if you
have anything that's like
a Raspberry Pi, which is like a
board that runs a full computer
that runs an operating system,
you can probably run Node
and Johnny-five on
it, which is awesome.
You can go to the web page and
there's a huge list of boards.
So if you have like an Edison
or one of the other boards,
it will still work on there.
So I usually encourage people
to use what you already have.
But the reason, given
no other assumptions,
I steer people towards
the Pi and the Uno
as a pair is because
they're ubiquitous.
They're everywhere.
People have lots of them.
The documentation and
community around both of them
is very, very rich and active.
And in case you do accidentally
burn one of them up,
they're pretty low cost.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, talk
a little bit about low cost.
Has there been a certain
shift over the certain number
of years and that's what's
made this so popular,
because of the shift
of cost coming down?
Has that been, I'm guessing,
a fairly large factor
in sort of the IoT space?
JEN TONG: Yeah.
If you look back
even a few years ago,
it was much more expensive to
get a device onto the internet,
mostly because of the
complexity in the software.
For example, when you're
writing code on an Arduino--
if you're just coding
on the Arduino--
you don't have an
operating system, usually.
So you lack things like virtual
memory and, importantly,
an internet stack and
an interim controller.
And then the rise of these
tiny, tiny, tiny full-fledged
computers suddenly
made it much easier
to get things connected
to the internet.
And around the same
time, the hardware
that allows you to connect
to Wi-Fi, like our existing
internet infrastructure, also
came down at the same time.
So it was kind of a
convergence of those things
over the last few years
that have suddenly
made this so much easier and
so much more fun to hack on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could
you give a little bit
of what you think might
happen in the future?
Do you think that
it's going to keep
on going and going to have
more and more little computers
everywhere?
What is your vision
of the future
of the Internet of Things?
JEN TONG: What is my vision?
That's a big question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is.
MARK MANDEL: And if
you get it wrong,
then we're going
to come after you.
And--
JEN TONG: Oh, no!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is recorded forever, so--
JEN TONG: That's so scary.
So my vision is we're just
going to get better and better
at building these electronics.
We're also going to
get better and better
at coming up with
the bag of tricks
for making these things work.
So on the electronics side, I
expect things to get cheaper.
Like one board that
came out recently
came almost out of nowhere.
It's called the ESP 8266, which
is this tiny little Wi-Fi chip
that's like $2.00.
And I'm starting to tinker
around a lot with it now.
And it's like the
cheapest way I've
seen to get devices onto Wi-Fi.
And I know a lot of people are
researching these Bluetooth
mesh networks and stuff, but
those protocols aren't ready
yet.
So everything I work on
now I usually use Wi-Fi
because it's already there.
And seeing suddenly
a huge drop in cost
shows me that that's not
going to be a big blocker
and we're going to have lots
of low cost electronics.
And then on the
flip side of that
is kind of our software
and design patterns,
is we're still leaning a
lot on the bag of tricks
that we developed for solving
web problems, you know,
loading web pages and
all that kind of stuff.
But as the way we build web
apps changes and mobile apps,
we're starting to come up with
new techniques for the way we
use caches and the way we
handle bursts of messages
and that kind of stuff, which
is going to make it easier
and easier to use existing
services, APIs, and open source
projects to solve
your IoT problems.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Very nice.
All right, well thank you
very much for joining us, Jen.
Is there anything at all that
we haven't talked about that you
want to talk about?
Have we missed anything?
JEN TONG: I guess though the one
thing that I would definitely
put out there is sometimes
people kind of go down
a rabbit hole on how they would
build a million of something
or a thousand of
something before they even
get their first jumper cable
into their bread board.
I would encourage
people to not focus
too much on the manufacturing
side, at least not
at the very beginning.
Spend time.
Like if you have an idea
you want to build something,
build one of something.
Don't worry about the
manufacturing later.
And then use that
one prototype you've
built to validate
your idea and get user
feedback, much the same way we
build mockups and scaffolding
in web applications.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, thank
you so much for all the insight.
That was a very
interesting conversation.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
JEN TONG: Yep.
You're very welcome.
It was a lot of fun.
Thanks for having me on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cheers.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
thanks so much to Jen
for joining us today.
A fascinating conversation.
I love that hardware stuff,
mainly because I just
don't understand a lot of it.
So any peek behind the magic
curtain that I can find-- it
makes me pretty happy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I know that I've been
playing a little bit more
with an Arduino.
And it's awesome.
You can really do so many cool
things in a quite easy way.
So yep.
Very excited about seeing
more of these things
related to the Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Definitely.
So moving onto our
question of the week,
this is an
interesting one, too--
a little bit less technical,
but I think just as important.
It's a question around is
there any Google Cloud Platform
certification or
training, like if you
need to be able to say yes,
I definitely know this thing,
how do you get that
piece of paper that
says that you definitely do?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
answer is, of course, yes.
There's actually a web
page with all the trainings
that we support.
And that link is actually
cloud.google.com/training,
quite obviously.
And you will find there a
bunch of different classes.
Some of the classes, like
CP100, CP200, CP300--
those are the main
classes where you're
going to learn about
general topics of the Cloud,
starting from what is the Cloud
and why how they store my data,
how they connect between
different instances, that kind
of stuff, to things that
are way more evolved.
Like you will be able to
see something very specific
about well, how do I package
my containers-- my Docker
containers-- to be
deployed onto a container
engine and stuff like that.
So you will find a bunch
of different trainings
and, also, certifications.
MARK MANDEL: I'm actually
looking through it.
I didn't honestly realize
that we had this many training
programs in here
from Docker packaging
and through to Cloud storage
through the App Engine--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, there's SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You can
find basically everything
you might be interested in.
MARK MANDEL: This is actually
really, really interesting.
OK, and a variety
of locations, too.
Some are online.
Some are actually physically
in particular places.
That's actually very cool.
I did not know that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it is.
It's a very interesting resource
because you will have access
to a lot of different material.
And then in the end,
you're pretty much
forcing yourself to study to go
through those certifications.
And once you get them, they're
kind of showing that, yeah.
You know what you're doing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's really interesting.
I was reading through the FAQ.
And it is worth noting
that you don't necessarily
have to take the training
course to pass the exams.
If you feel like you
have enough knowledge,
like you've worked
with it enough,
we're never going to stop you.
We recommend it, of course.
But nothing to
necessarily stop you.
So if you've been working with
a particular product for a while
and you want to have
that certification,
definitely something
you could go for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I think
it's definitely worth it.
And once you have the
certification, right now,
it doesn't expire, basically
because it's quite new.
But it's these kind of
things that, basically, you
want to do regularly, because
our products keep evolving.
So saying that you are
an expert on a technology
but you got that
certifications two years ago,
well, I mean it's
still valid, of course.
But it's always good to try to
refresh those certifications
if that's something that can
help your career, really.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That sounds pretty reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On top
of that, one resource
that I use very often is
actually not training,
but the solutions page.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
cloud.google.com/solutions.
And here, there our
solutions engineers share
use cases and white papers
about specifically how
to do some technical thing.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
some of the solutions that
are grouped by topic,
so you're going
to have Internet of
Things, for instance.
That's one of them.
But you're also
going to have gaming.
But at the same
time, you're going
to see also some stuff
that is really, really
specific, like a white paper
on how to deploy correctly
MongoDB on Google Cloud
Platform, stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's a
lot of different parameters.
So our solutions
engineers-- what they do
is they will write.
They will basically explain
what is the good value
for every single parameter.
What is the design
decision behind those?
So it's really,
really interesting
to go through some of
those white papers.
MARK MANDEL: So
if you're looking
to do like some sort
of, I don't know,
maybe a gaming
analytics platform
or something like that,
and you think to yourself,
how would I go about
doing that, going
through the solutions that
are already listed in there
can probably give you a
leg up to be like, OK.
This is our recommended
way of doing it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Definitely.
I think it's really good.
Our solutions engineers-- I
get to work with some of them
from time to time.
They're amazing.
They really, really
know what they're doing.
And they're really good writers.
So definitely, go have a look.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right, Francesc.
Should we let people
know where we're going
to be for the next few weeks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, by the
time this episode will be out,
I will already be in
Paris for the DevFest.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that's on February 5th.
We have DevFest Paris.
That's going to be lots of fun.
I'm going to be talking
about GRPC and Kubernetes
and everything [INAUDIBLE].
And I might try to do
the talk in French.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, good luck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's always fun.
People make fun of my
accent. [SPEAKING FRENCH]
I sound Canadian.
I don't know.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Still
the same stuff.
So I'll be on vacation
for a couple weeks,
but when I get back, I
have the Launch Hackathon,
which is always fun.
I always love doing hackathons.
And then on top of that, yep.
Game Developers
Conference-- still
got lots of plans
happening with that.
We'll definitely have a booth
space and events going on.
We're doing a
developer day where
you can talk to developers
and do a bunch of talks,
that sort of stuff, too.
So if you're interested
in gaming and Google Cloud
Platform, definitely
come and say hello.
We'd love to speak to you.
Then obviously, we'll
both be at GCP next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
We'll be there.
MARK MANDEL: Doing all
sorts of interesting stuff.
There may be something podcasty.
We'll see.
We'll see what happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll see.
It's still kind of
secret or even-- no.
We're not really sure
what's going to happen.
But it's going to be something.
MARK MANDEL: Something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For sure.
MARK MANDEL: Something
will be happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We'll see.
And then after that, I'll be at
Strada, running some stuff down
there as well, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So before we say
goodbye, I think
it's a great moment to refresh
how to get in contact with us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, and we
definitely want interaction
and we definitely want
the comments and support.
So please, definitely
send things through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, so I'm going
to go with every single
media, and you say the--
MARK MANDEL: OK, let's do it.
Let's do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So first of all
is our web page--
MARK MANDEL: Gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--and our email.
MARK MANDEL:
Hello@gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then we
have a Twitter handle.
MARK MANDEL: Gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
have a subreddit.
MARK MANDEL: Subreddit,
which is /r/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And finally,
we have Google Plus--
MARK MANDEL: --at
google.com/plusgcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So yeah, as always, if
you have any questions,
we're always looking for
questions of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Or cool things.
If you've got something
that's particularly exciting,
we'd love to see it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If you
want to have some topic
covered or you're
doing something
amazing with the
Google Cloud Platform
and you want to
tell us about it--
MARK MANDEL: Come on
the podcast, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Come on the podcast.
We're always happy to
interview new people.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, thank you so much for
joining me yet again, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And
see you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]